Justin Warner here,
the man with the fans.
And in order to get in
the spirit, my friends,
check it out.
How cool is that?
These are the Black Panther
claws produced by Hasbro.
And they're really putting
me in the spirit of things.
You can show off your
fiercest Wakandan salute.
You got lights.
You got actions.
And man, that sounds sharp.
Speaking of sharp, I'm
over here with Brandon.
And Brandon, you're
looking mighty good.
Thanks, Justin.
Thank you, man.
So I understand you're a
huge Black Panther fan.
And I got to know.
Can you tell us a little bit
about your cosplay tonight?
Of course.
So what I'm actually
wearing is King Azzuri,
who is the grandfather
of King T'Challa.
Wow.
So you got the whole family
lineage and everything.
Yeah.
Eventually, I'm going
to do King T'Chaka
too, along with Black Panther.
So as a Black Panther
fan, I got to know.
What inspires you from the film?
Really, what inspires me most
is the end scene where Wakanda
finally makes the
decision to open up
its borders to the world, to
share technology because unity,
I feel like, is what
it's all about--
working together
with other nations,
working with other
cultures and stuff.
And I love what
Marvel and Disney--
how they're incorporating
more and more cultures,
setting the tone that
we as African-Americans
and people of color
had never seen before.
So this is
groundbreaking for me.
So we chatted a
little bit before.
And I think it's
not just important
for people of our age, but for
the next generation, as well.
And I understand that you
have a little cosplayer
waiting for you at home.
Yes, my son Braxton.
We love doing cosplay together.
I love dressing up.
He loves dressing up with me.
And we go to cons
and stuff like that.
We have so much fun together.
Well, Braxton, my
friend, it's your lucky day
because in partner with Hasbro,
we're handing out the Marvel
Legends Black Panther
premium electronic helmet
and Black Panther
Wakanda FX battle claws.
Awesome.
That's awesome.
Thanks, Marvel.
Yeah, right
there for you, man.
Hot diggity dog.
Today is a good day.
And for all of you at
home, you can, of course,
get your Black
Panther Wakanda battle
FX claws at your local Target,
Walmart, or online at Amazon.
And I just got to know.
I wonder, do you think Hasbro
makes a set of matching abs?
Man, I hope they do
make a set of matching abs
because I got dad bod.
So little matching
abs that go with this,
Hasbro, if you
have it, I need it.
I need it.